question que faire quand un produit a
été jugés par un état trop dangereux
pour être utilisée par sa population a
rien de plus simple il suffit de le
vendre à un autre état moins regardants
connaît le paraquat par exemple ou plus
exactement le dit chlorure de paraquat
cette substance est entre autres mortels
en cas d'inhalation toxiques en cas
d'ingestion par contact avec la peau et
peut causer des lésions aux organes en
cas d'exposition prolongée ou répétée
ah oui et au passage elle est aussi
soupçonné d'augmenter le risque de
développer la maladie de parkinson
vu le risque d'empoisonnement pour les
agriculteurs cette substance a été
interdite par lieu en 2007
le paraquat reste cependant l'un des
herbicides les plus utilisés à travers
la planète
et parmi ces fabricants on trouve le
géant agro chimique suisse syngenta qui
ont produit toujours en grande quantité
dans son usine située au royaume uni et
en a exporté 28 mille tonnes en 2018
principalement à destination des
etats-unis du brésil et du mexique
au total les ong public eye et
greenpeace uk ont identifié pas moins de
quarante et une substance interdite par
lieux qui ont malgré tout était produite
en europe en 2018 par une trentaine de
sociétés 81 mille tonnes de composer
phytopharmaceutiques dangereux pour
l'homme et où l'environnement ont été
vendus à quelques 85 pays dont les trois
quarts sont des pays émergents ou en
développement et tout ceci parfaitement
légalement et la france dans tout cela
l'hexagone étaient en 2018 le cinquième
exportateur européen de produits
interdits
mais bonne nouvelle paris a fait évoluer
sa législation il y a deux ans ces
substances ne pourront plus être
produite stocker ou même circuler dans
le pays à partir de 2022 reste qu'il
s'agit d'une exception en europe et qui
ne s'appliquera que dans 16 mois
lui continue de vendre au monde entier
des produits phytosanitaires qu'elle
juge trop dangereux pour ses propres
populations et d'importer des denrées
cultiver grâce à ces pesticides
interdits
un cynisme teinté d'absurde comme
bruxelles sait si bien le faire